[Music]
the traditional nutritional approach for
footballers has always been high
carbohydrate but of course we're now in
the year where we recognize that protein
is critical for training adaptations so
obviously nutrition is really important
between finishing the training session
and then starting the subsequent session
you know we want the players to take in
quality protein to recover from the
training that they've just done and then
also provide an adaptation for the
training that they're going to do
we've players I've done a hard training
session and we'll use the science in
support Rigo to provide a good quality
carbohydrate and protein source for the
players we use the protein bars which
the players can take with them you know
one that walk from the dressing room
into the gym and I also really like the
way xx it's a quality protein source
it's real convenient for the guys just
to pick up walk out to the dressing room
and start the next session protein is
important after the pitch based training
because there's a lot of recent treat
loads I change your direction
so yeah it's critical that they got
those proteins in and repair afterwards
probably it's not only gonna be
important for that repair but also for
growing new muscle if we've got players
there trying to grow and develop
physically especially in the academies
and with the younger players and even in
pre-season we left players at a losing
weight but we often increase the protein
there just to protect that lean mass and
make sure that they're not losing muscle
whilst they're losing body fat every
players got a bespoke program that the
following the gym and every players got
a plan that that's going to work through
outside you know the bespoke programming
has to be supported by appropriate
nutritional intervention so you know for
some of our players are they looking to
try and increase lean mass are they
looking to try and reduce fat mass are
they in an injured player that is
looking to try and do both at the same
time when our players are injured we
focus on open their protein a little bit
and then reduce the carbs a little but
making sure they've got that protein
there to repair and build new tissue as
soon as you do come back from injury
you've got to be ready to get back on
the pitch and train and
by carrying extra weight and that could
be massively detrimental to your return
[Music]